dans la lignée d'elizabeth taylor et
richard burton tom cruise et nicole
kidman ou angelina jolie et brad pitt
penelope cruz et javier bardem font
partie de ces couples mythiques de
cinéma à la ville comme à l'écran avec
everybody knows le film d'asghar farhadi
qui ouvrira la compétition cannoise
le couple espagnol partagé en flammes la
fiche pour la sixième fois l'occasion
pour chicza de rencontrer les deux
comédiens pour une interview cinéphiles
et speed dating
c'est l'heureuse élue qui ouvrira le 71e
festival de cannes mais aussi la
compétition le 8 mai prochain
everybody knows d'asghar farhadi après
le passé en 2013 et le client en 2016 le
réalisateur iranien d'une séparation est
en lice pour la troisième fois pour
décrocher la palme d'or en iran le
festival de cannes c'est un événement
très important
chaque année beaucoup d'iraniens
viennent à cannes d'ailleurs abbas
kiarostami a remporté la palme d'or
après son escapade française avec le
passé farhadi a choisi de tourner hors
des frontières de son pays en espagne et
en espagnol avec le couple royal
penelope cruz et javier bardem
et on peut dire casse car farhadi porte
chance à ses acteurs à cannes puisque
bérénice bejo pour le passé et shahab
hosseini pour le client et ont tous deux
remporté les prix d'interprétation
de bonne augure pour penelope cruz et
javier bardem qui incarne ici d'anciens
amants réunis pour un mariage et qui
vont être confrontées à un drame
inattendu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ragot penelope penelope bonjour comment
ça va très bien et très bien merci à ce
qu'un paradis a écrit le scénario pour
vous il avait très envie de travailler
avec vous depuis longtemps comment vous
êtes rencontrés qui comme effet il m'a
appelé il y a cinq ans a joué comme vous
pouvez vous imaginer j'ai été vraiment
ravi de cet appel parce que je suis une
immense fan de son travail au ce prix il
n'y avait pas de scénario mais il m'a
raconté l'histoire et est je me suis
engagé à faire le clown poète il y a
quelque chose de très poétique chez lui
spécial bons jours javier ravi de vous
rencontrer
elle veut badine aux se passe en espagne
mais le réalisateur et d'étrangers
c'était aussi le cas avec woody allen
pour vicky cristina barcelona et
inarritu pour biutiful et tout ça vous
plaît d'avoir une vision étrangères de
l'espagne
dia oui j'avais pas travailler avec un
réalisateur espagnol en espagne en
espagnol depuis mardi entre avec
amenabar en 2003 donc je vous laisse
imaginer
je pense que la distance ça apporte une
perspective sur les choses belles heures
à ce que le fait qu'à ce gars créé ce
petit monde espagnol avec sa vision
d'étrangers ronson
ça aide à comprendre qu'ils ont nés en
tant qu'espagnol hausse par les agents
des deux bâles choix been very penelope
vous êtes beaucoup impliqué
émotionnellement sur ce fils j'ai
entendu dire que vous avez fini dans une
ambulance après avoir joué une scène de
crises de panique attaque liesse et l'os
h au louis c'était une scène courte mais
très intense et
et je pense que j'étais vraiment en
train d'y perdre ventilés et du coup
quand j'ai voulu sortir de la voiture
j'ai failli tomber ma glycémie à
augmenter ma tension a chuté d'un
sourire et j'ai fini dans une
quand je suis sorti on a enchaîné
directement sur une nouvelle crise ça
montre à quel point on est fou non un
métier de passion qui lie le couple
cruise bardem avec everybody knows c'est
la sixième fois qu'ils sont réunis à
l'écran après des films comme en chair
et en os de pedro almodovar wisco bar le
mois dernier leur première rencontre
elle a eu lieu il y à 22 ans sur le
tournage de jamon jamon de bigas luna
il a attiré mon attention tout de suite
je me suis dit cette personne a beaucoup
de talent je me souviens que je me suis
dit qu'il avait une force incroyable
j'avais 16 ans j'en avais 21 et pour
nous c'était vraiment la meilleure
manière de débuter notre carrière
autre moment fort de leur filmographie
commune vicky cristina barcelona en 2008
devant la caméra de woody allen penelope
cruz et javier bardem incarne des amants
volcaniques
ironie de l'histoire c'est sur ce
tournage que débute l'idylle entre les
deux comédiens
dix ans plus tard penelope cruz et
javier bardem semble plus que jamais
inséparables bing le fait d'être marié
ce que ça vous aide à jouer ce type de
relation intime de l'iphone chez les
absents ont fait dans le sens où il ya
de la confiance de la confiance et du
respect non et puis ça aide parce qu'on
se connaît déjà très bien dans le sens
où on n'a pas à créer d'alchimie
l'alchimie est déjà là par contre c'est
important de bien séparer la fiction et
la réalité sont ne pas tout mélanger et
garder en tête que ce sont des
personnages différents de nous des
femmes pdc
en même temps ça ne veut pas dire qu'on
peut faire ça y est tous les ans vierny
non vous avez tourné ensemble trop
souvent ça marcherait pas mais une fois
loin c'est génial c'est fini le film
s'intitule everybody knows what devrions
tous savoir sur javier est sûre penelope
et lopez ou alors sur elle je vous
laisse lui demander quant à moi ce qu'il
y à savoir ce que je veux bien vous dire
ni plus ni moins je lis des livres de
médecine tous les jours c'est quelque
chose que peu de gens savent et reed est
vraiment je lis des livres de médecine
épais comme ça je vais tous les jours
mais raide et mais alors peut-être que
c'est parce que je suis hypocondriaque
en tout cas c'est ce que je dis mais je
suis hypocondriaque docteur penelope
c'est mon hobby qui titre
[Musique]